so a few things if they're if they're
just starting out in recruitment and
they know that one day they want to work
for themselves the best thing they can
do right now is focus on their
reputation in every single conversation
that you have if you just do the right
thing by people you're going to just as
a byproduct build that fantastic
reputation and that's going to be super
helpful
when you go to set up on your own i've
seen a few people
try and set up on their own without that
reputation to fall back on and that's
when it's risky really and there's
always an element of risk when you set
up on your own but you want to try and
eliminate that risk wherever you can and
that's one of the areas you can
if you um
if you are sort of like a couple of
years into recruitment i would say once
you get into like a senior consultant
role from that point i'd say you'd
really want a couple of years in a
senior role to get as much experience as
you can and as much much exposure as you
can to
how that business runs
um
how
to lead people coach people support
people just try and just be a sponge and
learn it all
and
start at that point saving up basically
so one of the things that
was
i don't know if we would still be here
if i hadn't have done this because
obviously the pandemic hit nine months
in and there's always going to be
the economy to contend with always um
but i started saving
money
to cover
six months worth of my wage gave
yourself a six month runway yeah and as
it happened i stretched it out to 12
months i just
scrimped for 12 months but without that
i bought myself time there to do it
right and not to feel that pressure to
immediately bill and make the wrong
decisions like everyone in recruitment
will know that if you're
if you're entering a month and you've
got your target to hit and you've not
really
you know had any kind of like forward
orders and you're going into a month on
zero
the pressure that you are then under
doesn't actually help anything doesn't
usually equal the results usually when
you
um
i suppose think ahead and you're always
a month ahead
it flows nicer and it's the same when
you're set up on your own you need time
to get it right the recruitment mentors
podcast is proudly sponsored by vincerie
and the award-winning sauce breaker